hey guys Ryan Wright is here I'm Jerry
so today we're gonna check out the
honest teaser for Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice people told us that we
should check this out let's see what's
going on it is by screen junkies screen
junkies yeah
they shoot movies into their bloodstream
you know what I like that one I like
that alright
[Music]
is it really surprising that a movie
star the two most iconic superheroes in
the world would be that's how it started
warner brothers casting Ben Affleck as
Batman the turn fanboys cruel
[Music]
to the beta teaser that will probably
generate ward
[Music]
definitely your favorite most created by
Christopher Nolan Superman created by
and continued profits for by ripping off
the killer directed by the slow-mo dude
these are brilliant we have a very
similar idea although theirs is much
better but we typically get ours was
just funny theirs was like geared to I
yeah we don't commentary on the trailer
that is exactly that is very much where
I wanted it to get to then we would
start releasing it but honest movie
trailers but it's fun that was really
funny yes it's really uh all the things
they're saying are so true things were
brilliant stuff I totally agree everyone
is talking about the voice same like is
it better than Christian Bale's but it
sounds like a voice modulator right
modulator no moduli sir
okay that's the thing that the first
time I heard it I was like oh he's got
some kind of you know microphone slash
voice modulator I don't know how people
are gonna feel about that because on the
one hand you think back to at least
Batman Begins before they started
distorting it and you're like kind of
makes sense just to have the guy talking
to you in a gruff voice versus check out
my stereo like well yeah I mean it made
sense because he does have to mask his
voice because also I never thought of
Batman as a guy who would want to be
loud oh yeah true you know I'm like
having our microphones like Wow
you know and when he does get loud it's
scary that man featuring Superman rushed
to the Justice League rush to the
Justice League everything they point out
these guys are so brilliant man they
have like the best staff other [ __ ] is
like amazing like why are they so good
at what why are we not that good no I I
just set up a whole new world of comics
to come into feedback though you doosre
like the trailers in the Nana be like no
we do movie reviews review the trailers
we do short films and sketches instead
see if this parts gonna make it into the
final video it is anyway guys thanks for
informing us you informants if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects Jerry has a playlist on
this channel it's a really good playlist
that consists of movie reviews primarily
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where Jerry is
constantly posting pictures of his
what's the spot in between the balls in
the battle the Gooch that's one word for
it
the attaint is the the preferred
parlance of the current we go Gooch
sounds funnier Jerry's Gooch no there is
not one picture that you'd like no he is
full of lies they're pictures I took of
your huge that is also true